so Rashid Rasheeda Talib came out and
said that she was very sober about
impeachment she's actually laughing out
loud about how she was headed down to
the floor and then it turns out that
after the Democrats told I mean
literally told everybody in the party do
not cheer do not applaud Nancy Pelosi
had to give them the stank eye when they
started after she announced the
impeachment charge had gone through this
is very awkward moment where grandma was
telling the kids to knock it off here's
Emperor Palpatine grandma article one is
adopted yeah yeah
awkward moment because they weren't sad
sober serious any of that
okay here's that Rashida to lead clip I
am on my way to United States House
floor to impeach President Trump on
behalf of my incredible district
thirteen districts Rock she hasn't been
this happy since Hamas was firing
rockets at Jews I mean this is like it's
a big day for a shoot at the liebe big
day for Ishita Talib yeah they were so
serious they were so somber even Nancy
Pelosi was somber which is why she came
out like today and then said that she
has a spring in her step over over this
whole thing and she said this she did a
press conference she was wearing red eye
red is her happy color black is her I'm
sad and sober and somber and serious red
is her I'm robust and happy and
everything's great
here's Nancy police saying that she's
got us shine on her shoes Ana melody in
her heart here she is we've been hearing
from people all over the country and the
last since last night and this morning
seems like people have a spring in their
step because the president was held
accountable for his reckless behavior no
one is above the law and the
Constitution is the supreme law of the
land no one is above the law and the
president has been held accountable Wow
spring in their step but I thought we
were sober and satins
in somber and so burns head and serious
and sober and somber speaking of that
sort of sobriety
I really appreciated Democrats really
showing how deeply upset they were about
the Ukraine's stuff particularly that it
wasn't about ancillary issues it was
mostly just about Ukraine
it wasn't about their underlying unease
with the president it wasn't about the
fact I hate him it was about Ukraine and
so here are a bunch of Democrats talking
about how serious sober somber they are
about the Ukraine charges and then never
mentioning Ukraine that's exciting stuff
here is a representative at jan
Schakowsky a house key from illinois
explaining that her son convinced her to
impeach long before ukraine my adult son
i in Schakowsky whom I will always
credit for my decision last june to
support an impeachment inquiry it had
never been my goal to impeach a
president but i in made such a
compelling case he reminded me of the
oath I have taken eleven times now to
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States he said mom this is
not about politics this is not about
party oh is that what he said amazed how
many members of Congress do the old
Jimmy Carter my daughter told me to
worry about nuclear war routine and then
you got representing Jackie Speier who
says that if we don't impeach Trump then
basically will turn into Nazi Germany
which is a hell of a claim here is
Jackie Speier from California my father
fled Nazi Germany for America because he
saw what happened when a despot became
untethered he fled because he believed
in democracy in the rule of law and the
right to vote um so he fled and what
you're afraid of is that will now mimic
Nazi Germany I would note that your
party recently covered for some vicious
anti-semites and that one of your
leading party candidates for president
has embraced all of those same
anti-semites also can we like not do the
orange Hitler routine you're not if we
don't ask Donald Trump it's just like
when my father fed Hitler
heads a Fuhrer Donald Trump would come
to your house and he will force you to
accept federal judicial appointments you
don't like just like
have wood in it's so tiresome so
tiresome
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content